it looks like you had fun whole [ __ ]
room was laughing at me you didn't even
say anything
where are you from missouri
i'll tell you one thing i did shows in
st louis a couple months ago i almost
died it was a whole story anyway the
point is
there's missouri and there's missouri
missouri
that's missouri my man still got a
[ __ ] lanyard on his keys who does
that in 2020
bro you got one key on that thing why
you need four feet of rope for one key
are you a janitor why do you need that
many keys dog
and he just [ __ ] whips it around his
finger when he's talking about hunting
or whatever
now i was getting a nice eight point
buck the other day
what do you do for a living man you're a
personal trainer
what about you guys you guys all know
each other from the health and fitness
world he's my trainer
yo is that your husband
you gotta [ __ ] this dude up yo i can't
hey bruh
are you out of your goddamn mind i'm
gonna let my wife bring a personal train
this guy just makes you feel good about
yourself all day and now we just hanging
out in the dark together
[ __ ] that dog you better start feeding
sneaking oreos into her dessert and
blame him this chicken tastes sweet i
don't know what
happened i don't know and then if she
doesn't lose weight like it's the
trainer i think she's not very good
let's get rid of him
get this guy the [ __ ] out here dude
that's your trainer how you know the
rest of these people
she brought you i don't like this one
bit yo
i'm engaged she's a pretty girl my
wife's a pretty girl i want some [ __ ]
good looking
ass dude teaching her how to lift
weights and laughing with her
she gets a personal trainer is that
[ __ ] hanging out with y'all
never right ever never i see how you
hold her hostage that's
love right there that's real love g's up
you know i mean you ain't going
nowhere [ __ ] right here grab the
[ __ ] wrist where you think you're
going
bathroom all right i'm timing you
out here giving out [ __ ] numbers on
my watch you're a good man dude you're a
saint
i'm a good man i wouldn't let that
happen i'm too insecure you're a secure
guy
i hope you appreciate this guy right
here as much as you appreciate the
[ __ ] trainers
who you've got a trainer too that [ __ ]
ain't here
where that [ __ ]
[Applause]
he left her at her house where she
[ __ ] supposed to be
this guy's sitting here at the end of
the table he knows he don't belong
looking embarrassed at the [ __ ] end
sitting here slump shoulder he got great
posture he's a personal trainer he
normally sits up [ __ ] right
he here he's slunk he's like i don't
know man this is weird
that's an odd thing i don't think he
wants me here i don't think this is like
a cuckold thing i think i'm just
here for no reason she ain't even let
you bring a [ __ ] date doug
i don't like it one bit that's a good
man dude you're a [ __ ] good guy let
me tell you something
how long you been with your wife
eight years that's long enough to get
disrespected a little bit again but i
still don't like that [ __ ]
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty
you